well there's so much noise about Tim
Cook and Apple and the government
whether it's this Apple situation or
broader has technology moves so quickly
that the government simply can't keep
pace enough to regulate it in a smart
and effective way well it is a challenge
to update the policies including those
issues of when does the government have
a right to know having a really good
debate about when is that appropriate in
the extreme view that the government
always gets everything nobody supports
out having the government be blind
people don't support that so whether
it's this particular case or a few
others that are in the court were you
blindsided a bit like a min this morning
and so headline saying Bill Gates backs
FBI yeah I was disappointing because
that doesn't state my view on this i I
do believe that that with the right
safeguards there are cases where the
government on our behalf
like stopping terrorism which could get
worse in the future that that that is
valuable but striking that that balance
clearly the government's taken
information historically and used it in
ways that we didn't expect going all the
way back say to the FBI under J Edgar
Hoover so I'm hoping now we can have
have the discussion I do believe there
are sets of safeguards where the
government shouldn't have to be
completely blind and what specifically
should be done in this case just because
you were blindsided and we didn't get
your exact message well the courts are
gonna decide this and I think Apple said
that whatever the final court decision
is they'll abide by in the meantime that
gives us this opportunity to get the
discussion and and these issues will be
decided in in Congress the Patriot Act
how that gets evolved you don't want to
just take the minute after a terrorist
event and swing that direction or do you
and don't want to completely swing away
from government access when you you get
some abuse being revealed do you want to
strike that balance that the United
States leads in setting an example do
you think the privacy is in the same
stage now as environmentalism was when
you perhaps when you were younger that
it's one of those issues that so
people are going to come and work at
Microsoft the sort of people are going
to work at Apple it's becoming as
fundamental to them as greenery it was
to a previous generation well everybody
wants to feel like their information is
is kept private particularly because
more and more of your activity is in
there in that digital log then again
when they put it all up and they are
empowered by technology in terrorist
activities
they can't it's not just that they can
kill a few people it's through nuclear
biological they could kill a lot so we
do want the government to be out there
trying to stop those things from
happening